tous les jeudis danser que vous
l'attendez les chéris boukili cadets
révélé sur la révélation de fer sur les
chroniqueurs et aujourd'hui dur à des
questions également pour moi même sur
twitter pouvait poser des questions aux
chroniqueurs à moi même
on va y répondre voilà pendant toute la
durée de l'émission tout ce qu'on a
cette semaine je n'ai rien vu des images
comme d'habitude mais là encore moins
que d'habitude ce qu'on aura la même pas
parlé effectivement ça bien comment ça
va cette semaine fabien ben barka
c'est ma quatrième semaine oui je vais
ça j'aime beaucoup vos costumes pour
semblait vraiment rien cette fois
toujours une petite comme ça il est en
tout cas vous êtes bien vous avez bien
été intégré l'équipe ça fait plaisir à
oued aux aimants laisser le passage
d'ailleurs c'est grâce au super conseil
de mathieu jean michel on écoute
les regarder jouer
tu vas tu arrivais pas
[Applaudissements]
c'est au tour de vis de l'équipage et
des bouts de passer bon sapin 6 pas
j't'adore t'adore du sport avec toi mais
par des jeunes pour qui on à cronat quoi
donner matière à écouter tous ces
conseils ou pas toi d'abord j'ai énoncé
rentrer sa ressortie à d'accord très
bien comme souvent chez alors ces mecs
séquence préférée c'est sûr vous
évidemment si je la regarde le parfois
avant de dormir sous avec moi dans l'axé
mais je vous êtes ce que vous voulez
c'est l'intéressé effectivement quand
vous êtes jaloux les femmes vous aime
vous savez votre connerie c'est non pas
que les femmes et les femmes pardonnant
personnes de même anxieux merci en tout
cas merci merci pour voter alors
bouclent pas leur place à ma séquence
montbrison jamais c'est quoi le bail à
kaunas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sa grand mère ouais ouais
ouais je peux plus me supporter sur la
tête de ma mère
et comment
qu'est ce que vous pensez quand vous
vous regardez avec un petit peu de recul
comme ça qu'on adore wen avait toujours
dit que vous étiez bien dans votre corps
[Rires]
est toujours s'aimer soi-même pour aimer
les autres
vous aimez beaucoup de gens ouais c'est
vrai non bah oui oui mais au maquillage
quand vous passez devant le miroir vous
dites j'ai de la chance d'être aussi
beaumont du reste je suis sans déconner
avec moi vous regardez vous faites comme
ça et maison pas et après vous êtes on a
vu ça là que les muscles à vue
tout à l'heure j'ai remarqué que j'avais
un nouveau muscles sur le mois j'avais
pas que ça avait été bâtie comme lui on
serait tous les médias je suis bien trop
beau ça me stresse est fou ça me stresse
limites dans ma vie des beautés dire des
conneries rémittente et montois sorti au
bout de deux heures à venir
alors on a d'autres choses book oui vous
connaissez le fameux quart d'heure son
filtre de l'émission bien sûr j'adore
c'est un débat enflammé où les
chroniqueurs doivent répondre à la
question posée par oui ou par non
donnera tout à l'heure jusque là ça a
l'air simple ouais non l'été ça l'est
beaucoup moins
on regarde vous a préparé un magret cas
pour regarder alors que la promotion de
son nouveau film the two et non oui non
en cours de beauté
[Musique]
alors
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas les remarquer son teint mat
auber hélène pas d'y faire mais je ne
sais pas vous savez pas boucher moussavi
aujourd'hui la question est simple
est-ce que vous avez soit pareil
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
poulin s'éprend d'une pancarte sais pas
pourquoi c'est ça oui non tout à l'heure
ça va être un danseur de leurs habitants
disent installé cours - celui-là et de
leurs maux c'est là que l'on va laisser
regarder leur a préparé un magret cas
pour regarder alors que la promotion de
son nouveau film j'ai tué non oui non
oui non sur concours miss france
un concours de beauté
[Musique]
alors
[Applaudissements]
alors elle accroît la maîtrise de
l'antenne un bateau c'était vraiment les
gens les moins bons qu'ils traiteraient
pas eu la mâchoire de leur vol
oui alors jean mi sava janvier très bien
je tenais à vous féliciter jean be vous
êtes redevenu le grand jour nice
d'autrefois vraiment ça fait plaisir à
voir
son boss mois et de l'investigation une
diction quasi parfaite et un scoop de
fou c'est aussi ça jean michel maire
[Musique]
sur quoi tu es pas de scoop du géant
batave un gros problème en ce moment un
gros problème en ce moment on m'avait
dit ils m'ont traitée en bout et couche
et va bientôt avoir pendant l'émission
est à boire pendant l'émission toi parce
que je n'ai scoop a donné donc toi j'ai
discuté demain des scouts a donné
d'accord est donc mitigé moment alors
qu'on sait jamais
tu là
aura des infos sur ce chef d'état qui
travaillent ici j'aime bien caution vers
les gens donc suite à l'élimination
clara morgane ce samedi j'ai eu
quelqu'un la production de tf1 qui m'a
dit que c'était le feu nucléaire
la tf1 à cause de dalles ce drame
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était un jour parce qu'il est venu
boire la fin de l'émission sur la
première balle cyril j'ai pas dis moscou
qui d'autre ne vous inquiétez pas à
l'ancien janvier n'est pas trop trop
loin non plus d'ailleurs en vous
écoutant j'ai parfois l'impression
d'être sur votre canapé en pantoufles
chez papy quoi je suis ok chez janvier
c'est parti ouais
[Musique]
les péniches le leader tenir vous allez
allez allez piquante non non de peynier
al arabia tard il en fait si c'est plus
le déjà les garçons quoi départ système
pileux les garçons
organe autour de fond ce que pour les
images d'hélicoptères de la france c'est
pas fini ça reste une telle action je
t'aime
[Applaudissements]
quand je vois un éléphant s'asseoir sur
un pouf
alors quand j'aurai exhaler dans la
nature ils ne le font pas ils ne le font
pas dans la nature on est d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je veux toi
majeau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une heure j'ai regardé avec beaucoup
d'admiration va dire l'admiration à 6 et
10 kg de poissons et oui non mais c'est
la même tenue poisson regardez pas
regarder qu'elle est plutôt va vous
regardez plutôt mais c'est quoi ce
regard-là et ça m'a regardé jusqu'où les
la robe les stats il aime les belles
choses
oui bon respect pour que les exactions
les deux je sais on parlait de vous êtes
très amis vous appelez tout laissera pas
tous les sommets donc je sais qu'à 3
heures du matin si je me cherchais
quelqu'un c'est sûr a dit me plaît aussi
[Rires]
m
[Applaudissements]
bout qui à l'instar d'apple cookies
ouais ok oui j'ai fait un petit top 3 de
vous un civil ah oui oui c'est vraiment
nécessaire
oui oui chaque semaine c'est nécessaire
non mais écoutez moi merci alors qu'ils
ont pris ces petites phrases comme à
dire ah ben voilà lunaire allez faisons
du plaisir
allez salut les tutus salle une étude
[Musique]
et vous
fou
[Musique]
pour maquiller un peu maxime il est
blanc on dirait mon cul
[ __ ] vendredi soir gérant d'aprimo
pour un discours m'a bouffé tout le
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup pour quelqu'un qui n'est pas
concerné et non oui bah oui bah c'est
souvent quand on n'est pas concerné
conte au portail
je sens bien mon chef est lourd mais
j'ai pas compris la fin tout le coin oui
c'est quoi je sais même pas moi même
voix la salvetat fait de la gymnastique
et moi merci alors berne qui passons
autre chose allez on va pas s'attarder
là dessus alors oui elle est on a un
autre nouveau couple dans l'équipe
non ce qui c'est jean michel et fabien
non oui alors les deux compères ont
vraiment sont vraiment dans la sur la
même longueur d'onde 1 c'est vrai que
marc dutroux
allez on regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
je jure j'ai deux régimes locaux
c'est les brûler
comment il a fait
[Musique]
brisée
je sais
les gérer
il
saison
jour 3 g
[Musique]
vraiment insiste gros naze
[Applaudissements]
alors est très sympa ça il s'en passe
des trucs à dire vas tu as toi qu'est-ce
qu'on a d'autres machins et bien encore
du jean-michel à jean michel est ce que
vous êtes du genre susceptible pas du
tout pas du tout au bas du dos parce
qu'il faut surtout pas oublier de vous
dire aurevoir apparemment break à urdos
avec un invité qui a oublié de dire au
revoir il paraît que vous êtes très peu
vexé ah bon regardez-la propos merci à
vous merci à venir
[Musique]
quand on veut dire au revoir
rayon
paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lopo parce qu'il utilise en plus ce qui
est très sympa d un amour de mecs et en
plus le pauvre il est timide autour du
puits qui va tirer le bras mais c'est
bon c'est bon voila merci aller en un
petit fruit comme tu es dernier truc moi
chérie oui on a un petit truc si vous
voulez j'ai dit à quoi je te soit prise
de court là on va faire une petite pause
info quand même parce que je suis quand
même une rapide 1 et culture aussi
pendant les pubs les chroniqueurs se
racontent leur vie ah ouais et
franchement c'est souvent très palpitant
j'aime bien voir passionnant vas-y mon
bébé vient chercher mais qui vont un
jour c'est parce que
ceux qui marchent pas évoquer merde
faty dans
non
samba
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une question qui est arrivé les chéri
j'ai une question
oui allez-y dites moi dit moi je crois
qu'on va demander
on m'a demandé s'il vous plaît les
questions non ça c'est qu'ils savent que
ça va une question pour toi je voulais
savoir quel est selon toi le chroniqueur
le plus difficile à virer voilà je vous
fais des bisous à tous et je vous adore
si chéri elle est très belle un vendeur
de riz alors le chroniqueur le plus
difficile à gérer il n'est pas là si si
regardez
j'avais prévu cette question avant ce
qu'on l'a eue avant p&g la réponse en
images regard ah si je la photo alors le
chroniqueur le plus difficile à gérer je
vous le dis parce qu'ils n'ont pas le
magnéto je leur avais demandé de faire
un magnéto pour moi le chroniqueur le
plus difficile à gérer
giuly c'est fabien c'est non c'est pas
faire ces matchs de langues oui c'est
matthieu delormeau bien entendu mais qui
est néanmoins un énorme talent
exactement alors par ses gros zoom est
ce qu'on joue avec delormeau et organes
ou est-ce qu'on joue avec matthieu
delormeau et on perd il vous coûte aussi
cher
qu'est ce cas il vous coûte aussi cher
les regarder maintenant mathieu peut
être difficile à gérer je vous le dis
parce qu'ils ne retrouvaient magnéto
même pendant les pubs
ils attaquent les gens taxés quand
regardez c'est plutôt lui qui se veut ta
question
non
nora
[Applaudissements]
ah bon
c'est ça
ce qui
[Applaudissements]
on adore ou l'adorent malheureusement au
ladakh rien il a un côté que la vieille
à jonah hill et j'adore ce mec
voilà je trouve qu'il fait une rentrée
exceptionnelle autriche je dis ça je
vous le dis c'est un génie forcément
c'est un génie et sachez le chez vous il
ne prépare rien et il est très très très
drôle mathieu et c'est pour moi
voilà c'est un très très grand talent
pour moi je le dis franchement je vous
jure c'est le plus grand talent qui est
à la télé en ce moment à une trêve
vraiment je le dis il est bien au dessus
de beaucoup d'animateurs qui ont plus de
travail
enfin je théâtre - mathieu qu'est ce que
vous m'avez bien jean one man show merci
pour qui d'avoir été avec nous mais
bercy